[Música]
[Aplausos]
ustedes creen que es posible mover a
todo el mundo a un punto donde haya cero
tolerancia a la corrupción
yo me levanto de repente en las mañanas
bueno todas las mañanas me tomo un café
me siento a leer las noticias y para
cuando acabo
os juro que creo que ya no se puede
descubrió que creo que es imposible
pero no me quiero sentar a llorar todas
las mañanas pero no puedo porque eso me
dedico yo no me dedico a ayudar a llorar
me dedico a combatir la corrupción
no creo que necesiten que les cuente
mucho para que se hagan una imagen de lo
que significa la corrupción todos
tenemos una imagen en la cabeza
muchas de esas veces la imagen es
increíblemente trágica como el año
pasado cuando se cayó el edificio de la
álvaro obregón y murieron 49 personas
porque alguien decidió ponerle un techo
extra a un edificio sin permiso
fue también super trágico y doloroso
cuando 151 departamentos fueron
consumidos en flamas en el centro de la
ciudad de londres
que además del dolor de perder gente y
perder vidas y perder casas la gente que
esperaba recursos para los damnificados
una concejal decidió robarse los para
irse de vacaciones 61 mil dos euros
-bueno libras ya no estoy confundiendo
se los robó para irse de vacaciones
también fue super super trágico y
doloroso cuando rana plaza en bangladesh
se cayó un edificio completo matando a
1.100 personas y 2.500 heridas toda esa
gente trabajaba en maquilas haciendo
ropa
y estaban haciendo ropa para empresas
que decidieron darle la vuelta a sus
normas locales e ir a corromper
eligieron ir a corromper allá en otro
país en otro país que no es el suyo y
eso nos costó 1.100 días
con estas imágenes cómo podemos como
podemos todos nosotros aquí
reconstruir nuestra vida social cómo
podemos crear una brújula ética que nos
guía siempre el camino a dónde tenemos
que ir de qué es lo que está bien y qué
es lo que está mal y que cada vez que
nos empecemos a desviar hacia el tema de
la corrupción nos regrese nos regresa y
nos marca el norte de lo que es
aceptable dentro de nuestras comunidades
cómo podemos hacer algo así cuando le
acaban de dictar sentencia a un ex
gobernador que se robo 61 mil millones
de pesos
61 mil millones de pesos es el
presupuesto de 2 años de quintana roo
con absolutamente todo escuelas
programas sociales lo que se imaginen 2
años del gobierno local es el fondo de
retiro de duarte
es inadmisible con esto hablar de
brújulas éticas con estos niveles de
dinero y de alma y de avaricia pareciera
que es ingenuo
especialmente cuando cada día cada
semana sale un nuevo escándalo de
corrupción
odebrecht paradise papers hasta la fifa
se la fifa a la gente que juegue fútbol
y que se llena de endorfinas y que es un
momento súper alegre ni siquiera ahí la
avaricia encuentra un límite
además la corrupción puede además de
matar también quita sueños quite
historia brasil lo sabe perfectamente
porque ahorita está llorando 200 años de
historia que se quemó en el museo
nacional
por corrupción
la corrupción pareciera que no tiene
límites ni siquiera fronteras porque se
extiende de hecho encuentras socios
globales pasando las fronteras pero lo
difícil lo más difícil es que mientras
más lejos está el afectado menor es mi
indignación menor es mi dolor y menor es
mi grito
yo como mujer feminista además estoy
increíblemente consciente de lo que
significa hacer la otra edad
ser el distinto no ser la norma ser el
otro que no es parte de mi comunidad no
es como yo entonces lo puedo
deshumanizar su dolor no me duele su
dolor no lo siento porque es lejano
en este mundo nos vamos nos vamos
alejando de las personas cada vez más
están allá los negros van allá los
indios están allá los del sur los de
otro país las mujeres los niños los que
no son como yo y entonces no me importa
ni me voy alejando del dolor y de la
indignación y si le pasa a otro entonces
no me importa porque no me pasa a mí
porque no son de mi comunidad
el antónimo de la corrupción no es la
honestidad
el antónimo de la corrupción es la
comunidad
lo único que nos puede ayudar a acabar
con este cáncer es reconocer a los otros
que son diferentes y toda su increíble
diferencia no es diferente a la mía es
parte de mi comunidad llena de colores
hasta que yo no puedo reconocer que los
otros son parte de mí no vamos a empezar
a crear fibras sociales fuertes
en esos huecos donde el tejido social es
endeble es que está la otra edad es que
está el individualismo y es que se
empieza a aflojar el tejido social y me
dejas de importar tú y como me dejes de
importar tu guardo mi brújula porque no
me importa si estoy haciendo bien o mal
porque es un interés personal pero
cuando te reconozco a ti como parte de
mí como parte de mi comunidad entonces
puedo empezar a pensar en plural a
pensar en colectivo
el sentido de comunidad
es en realidad el antídoto contra la
corrupción porque entonces cuando la
brújula apunte a mis intereses
personales yo sabré que estoy rompiendo
una tela fuerte un tejido fuerte lo
estoy destruyendo por intereses
personales y eso no se vale
eso definitivamente no se vale
en este mundo y no solo en méxico
tenemos una tolerancia bastante alta
para el tema de la corrupción porque al
final de cuentas sabemos que hay que
engrasar la máquina que si tú no en
grasas la máquina se atora especialmente
en países como el nuestro donde la
corrupción está hecha o más bien el
sistema está hecho para que todo se
mueva con corrupción
entonces cómo le haces cuando el sistema
tiene hasta para poder funcionar en este
sistema
tienes que engrasar la máquina no le voy
a preguntar a ninguno de los que son
aquí si ha sido parte de un acto de
corrupción porque estoy 100% segura que
han sido chiquito o grande pero han sido
parte del continuo de la corrupción
porque no hay manera de librarte porque
nuestro sistema está hecho para que
caigas para que absolutamente todo
todo caigas en la corrupción
imagínense ser una madre que no quiere
dejar a su hija en la escuela no quiere
pagar la cuota para ser parte de la
escuela para poder entrar a la escuela y
ella sola es la única que se niega
a pagar una cuota
la niña sería señalada y la madre sería
señalada por bolt osa por complicada en
este país no nos gusta en este país y en
este planeta no nos gusta hablar de
corrupción no nos gusta decir lo que
está mal nos da miedo nos apena nos
apenas nos apenas señalar y ser
señalados como el problemático el
revoltoso
pero necesitamos todos empezar a hacer
esos señalamientos porque son super
necesarios
en japón tuvo que renunciar al ministro
del viceministro de educación por haber
hecho actos de corrupción habían dicho
que era un país bastante honesto pero
hasta ya sea la corrupción y se dio isr
y renunció porque la tolerancia es mucho
menor a la corrupción de la que tenemos
nosotros
necesitamos movernos todos juntos y
juntas al lado de la resistencia para
poder acabar con el peor cáncer que
tenemos y eso es pensar en comunidad
porque todos aquí somos parte de la
comunidad y podemos elevar el valor de
lo que significa estar en esta comunidad
imagínense si todas las empresas y todos
los que están usted todos los que están
aquí todos ustedes mañana se levantan en
el espejo y piensa nada y sintió está
llorando seguramente algo tengo que
hacer para apoyarla en esta lucha contra
la corrupción yo tengo a mi comunidad de
cancún donde estamos trabajando para
acabar en contra la corrupción y hay
comunidad en todo el mundo tenemos miedo
pero si somos si todos juntos nos
movemos el miedo se acaba y la próxima
mañana que estés allí puedo apoyar yo
algo la comunidad puedo afinar mi
brújula y moverme hacia el lado de la no
corrupción cuando ustedes abandona la
comunidad subirá el nivel la calidad y
el beneficio para todos y se
multiplicará
a abonar a la comunidad es abonar contra
la corrupción el problema es muy
complejo y probablemente ustedes piensen
que lo que les estoy diciendo es
increíblemente idealista
pero a lo mejor ustedes no pueden ir a
combatir la corrupción de manera frontal
pero lo que sí pueden hacer es cada
mañana levantarse y elegir ser parte de
los que construyen comunidad y así con
una con una tela muy firme entre todos
vamos a construir algo distinto los
invito a que cada mañana reflexionen
frente al espejo si quieren ser parte de
la construcción o la destrucción de
nuestra sociedad y de nuestra comunidad
a fin en sus brújulas hagan algo por más
pequeño que sea todo cuenta y los invito
a que juntos construyamos una sociedad
con cero tolerancia a la corrupción
[Aplausos]
[Música]